[Musik]
was bedeutet wo man es ja schön mal
wieder ein video aufzunehmen euro
fröhlichen gesichter zu sehen wobei
wahrscheinlich gerade alle ungefähr
genauso wie dem auch sei ja zum beispiel
comrie video die mich und ich waren in
amerika hat eine echt geile reise hat
eine echt krank gezeigt das war mein
erstes mal in amerika und wir waren dort
um musikvideo zu drehen und haben uns
dadurch den ein oder anderen traum
erfüllt auf der einen seite natürlich
michael triegel die zum ersten mal einen
großen musik release gedrückt haben und
auf der anderen seite natürlich ich weiß
es war schon lange mein traum musik
videos zu drehen kreativ zu sein zu
reisen youtube wieder zu schneiden und
ich weiß nicht was hat sich damit so ein
bisschen
wir haben uns heute hier versammelt um
so ein bisschen zu klären wie genau dann
dieses musikvideo und vor allem diese
effekte entstanden sind also der basic
workflow war quasi dass ich das gefilmt
habe ich hab's ausländer für john
unseren von den dieser zeichnungen sind
hat ihnen das geschickt er hat dann
quasi darauf gezeichnet ich habe das was
er gezeichnet hat quasi auf dieses
filmmaterial wieder gelegt viele sachen
hat er schon so animiert dass sie zum
firma passen wie zum beispiel diese
partikel hier bei den pflanzen war es in
dem fall so dass ich die noch zum firma
tal bewegen musste damit das wirklich so
aussieht als würden die hier am
straßenrand stehen bewegungs- und
schaffen gemacht bald ihr seht dinge die
sich schnell bewegen die sind so
bisschen unscharf und wenn sie das nicht
tun dann fällt das unserem auge auf und
dann stört dann die quasi so durchs bild
und das ist natürlich durchaus habe
generell und champions league gemacht
das heißt dass dinge die näher an der
kamera sind unscharf sind dinge die
leute weg sind und im fokus inhalt
schach bleibend habe die farben
angepasst habe diese leuchteffekte dazu
gemacht die überall gesungen wir sind
bei den meisten shops war es so dass ich
quasi das filmmaterial strecken musste
das heißt ich kann natürlich nicht
diesen kaktus zb einfach so aufs bild
manchmal setzen weil dann würde der
einfach so herum fliegen sondern ich
muss ja sehen quasi mit animieren zum
filmmaterial damit auch so aussieht als
wäre dann wirklich auf diesen
zb das geht zu einem gewissen grade
automatisch mit acht effekt aber
meistens war es so dass ich dafür ein
anderes programm gebraucht habe und das
filmmaterial quasi 3d trekken musste das
kann ab jetzt will ich auch aber
deutlich schlechter und viele der show
werden allein mit effekt überhaupt nicht
möglich gewesen zu töten
diese information habe ich dann zurück
in afrika gebracht konnte dadurch diese
ganzen objekte im dreidimensionalen raum
antworten da wo sie hingehören dann muss
ich noch ganz viel aus maskieren weil
zum beispiel wenn jetzt objekte hinter
regie oder michael verschwinden da muss
ich natürlich die person ausschneiden
bild für bild und über dieses objekt
legen damit auch wirklich so aussieht
als würde das objekt dahinter
verschwinden dafür musste ich die beiden
meistens wirklich bild für bild aus
maskieren und das war echt ein enormer
zeitaufwand weil eine sekunde hatte in
dem fall 24 frames und dann muss ich das
24 mal ausschneiden quasi für jede
sekunde ihr könnt euch vorstellen was
das für ein kranker aufwand ist also ich
würde sagen wir gehen mal in acht rex
ryan hier möchte ich euch nämlich einen
meiner meinung nach sehr interessanten
schott zeigen und zwar der strudel
schott den strudel stadt haben wir quasi
hier sicher dass hier mit ja und wie im
green screen aufgenommen dass sie extrem
witzig aus bietet aber die möglichkeit
dass wir hinterher nicht micha und rewe
komplett neu zeichnen müssen sondern
dass ich mit verschiedenen effekten ihr
seht dass hier einmal die farbänderung
dann natürlich das ausziehen des grünen
hintergrund dann wie gesagt verschiedene
effekte auf die ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt genauer eingehen möchte außer
dass unter jedem dieser effekte wir
sehen auf hunderte andere kleine
einstellungsmöglichkeiten sind um auch
wirklich genau das zu bekommen was man
möchte
nachdem das fertig war hatte ich mich
dann dem strudel selbst gewidmet hat mir
der john diese form hier animiert welche
ich jetzt erstmal ein viertel weil ich
diese farbe für den strudel deutlich
schöner finde dann dupliziere ich und
positioniert die elemente im
dreidimensionalen raum so dass sie quasi
diesen tunnel hier geben und kopiere
immer wieder die einzelelemente dreh die
bisschen rum größe die ende die
deckkraft damit die ein bisschen
unterschiedlich aussehen und hier seht
ihr schon den tunnel der dadurch
entstanden ist nachdem ich die rotation
des strudels angestellt habe kommt
zusätzlich noch bewegungsunschärfe drauf
und dann können wir auch schon den micha
und den rewe quasi in diesen
dreidimensionalen strudel reinsetzen um
euch das möglichst simpel erklären zu
können habe ich übrigens hier nur
relativ wenige strudel elemente wenn man
diesen prozess das kopieren und einfügen
dass diese einzelnen elemente immer
wiederholt kommt man dann letztendlich
zu diesem ergebnis und ich wünsche euch
jetzt noch viel spaß mit dem musikvideo
ohne effekt
ein
schnell
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also ich glaube er konnte jetzt einen
ganz guten eindruck gewinnen wie ich das
gemacht habe wie viel arbeit darin
standen und wie die einzelnen schritte
ging das was mit diesem video ich hoffe
ja du warst schon
[Musik]